Kristen is with us in Alabama hi Kristen
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show how can
we help okay this is actually my first
time calling in to you but my mother has
listened to you for many many years and
she's followed a lot of your advice so I
figured I'd come to you myself okay how
can we help I'm in I got questions for
the both of y'all actually the first one
is I'm in 44 thousand and two hundred
dollars in debt total five thousand
comes from my credit card bills I have
for them
student loans fifteen thousand personal
loans 787 and my car alone is twenty
three thousand and four hundred good
lord okay and I've just recently moved
out of my mom's place and this is the
first time I've done this all on my own
how old are you I'm 30 okay so what's
your question what do I do to get out of
this huge sellers car what's your house
what do you make what's your income for
disability thirteen hundred and
forty-five a month and with my job about
450 a week yes you are I don't even know
how you qualified to get this loan is it
co-signed by your mother no sir I got
this all by myself
yeah so it's a high interest rate then
probably yeah this car is this cars
insanity honey it's killing you I kind
of figured either that or the student
loans yeah well you can't sell the
student loans well you can sell a car
get you a hope yes get you a thousand
dollar car with no payments so what are
you doing for income what's your job
I have I got my disability as I
mentioned and for my job I'm a call
center representative and you make 450 a
week yes sir okay should make it 17
bucks a month 1800 bucks a month just
about and due to my disability I'm
having to cut my hours I can't make
above a certain amount which the
question I have for your co-host today
is should I just drop the disability and
then just because I want to move up in
the company and I can't do that at the
disability it's hindering me I'm making
more than what I should yeah what's the
nature of your disability now SSI no I'm
saying what's wrong with you what's the
nature of your disability mental and
survivors my father passed away when I
was 8 years old with lung cancer and
brain tumors and so I'm sorry that is
this the trauma because of your father
passing at such a young age for you is
that what you're referring to
I showed different signs when I was a
young child but after my father passed
away it all came to a head okay are you
seeing somebody are you seeing a
professional counselor psychiatrist and
counselor okay Aaron I'm making progress
how you doing I'm stable enough that you
want to move up to the company right now
so what does move in to see the company
look like what would you make if you
move up to the company my co-workers
don't wanna give me the exact amount but
I'm hoping to make it up the team lead
right now I'm a supervisor to the
customers whenever would you mind hasn't
used to you how much would you make it
would be above in the $500 range
well you're making 450 now she answered
her own question should I move up I
would have to drop disability and I
think the answer is yes although it was
enough to justify the dropping of it
that's right so you know you've got to
run those numbers but I also want you to
talk to your professional counselor the
psychiatrist and say hey she's clearly
gone from somewhere to stable and what's
the path look like to go from stable to
healthy I'd want to know that and then
I'd want to run the numbers yeah and
then start laying out that's right let's
send you a copy of Ken's book the
proximity principle which will help you
identify some career
your directions and some things to do it
may not be as simple as just moving up
to the company you may have better
opportunities that make more money out
there yeah when you start just
rethinking hey what am I gonna do with
my life that's right I'm 30 when I'm 40
or 50 what do I want to be making what I
want to be doing and in the meantime you
need to get rid of car kiddo it's it's
absolutely destroying your mathematics
it's just destroying your finances